the kurfürstendamm starts on the
southwestern edge of the tier Garden
Park from the famous Kaiser Wilhelm gate
deafness Kershaw a bombed-out Church and
major landmark it stretches some three
and a half kilometers west the rotten
out plots the coup Dom as it's called is
known primarily as a major shopping mile
but it's also living breathing Berlin
history the vulture family is part of
that heritage Martin pivara is the third
generation of his family to run the
streets famous theater complex to people
like us being on the kurfürstendamm
really is something special you get a
lot of walk-in customers and it's always
busy over the decades in a microcosm
Martin's grandfather took over the
reigns of the Tata Rome Carlton DOM and
Commedia umka frost and Dom in 1934 the
two stages have repeatedly won rave
reviews for their popular productions
both were founded over 90 years ago by
legendary theater director Max Reinhardt
doesn t I here I'm Coopers and they were
built by Marx find her to be the first
comedy theaters in Germany yes Boulevard
are decent if I hoped as far as I got
the idea from London and Paris the big
city dwellers and with these two
theaters he laid one of the foundations
for the legendary reputation of the
kudos in the 1920s the Gwinnet the
street takes its name from the
prince-electors or Cerf roastin of the
surrounding state of Brandenburg
the kutab later became a magnet for
artists actors and writers as Berlin
boomed during the Roaring Twenties they
met at the streets countless coffee
houses cafe councillor is the only one
that survived the decades during the
Cold War the street became the beating
heart of West Berlin and when the Berlin
Wall fell in 1989 this was the first
port of call for many East Germans stop
this nice young man and he brought us to
the Kudo we had no idea where we were
the Kadam is also the destination of
choice for people celebrating Germany's
triumphs on the football pitch like last
summer's World Cup traffic comes to a
halt as thousands of fans take to the
streets but there is the odd island of
tranquility amidst all the hustle and
bustle this square is named after
pioneering Dada artist George gross
recently there's been a big effort to
redo the squares and corners on
Kurfurstendamm and this is a good
example
closing off this little street here has
liven up the place and it's cafes and
restaurants which can support the
further west you go things start to
quiet down there are fewer shops here
and there's even one of the front
gardens left every house used to have
them the Saturday farmers market that
later plots is worth a visit it's a
meeting point for real Berliners who
live on the kuda increasingly owners are
trying to rescue old structures take
cumberland house for example it fell
into a state of disrepair but
renovations in the last five years have
returned it to its rightful role as one
of the avenues stateliest buildings
the coffee shop on the ground floor
which has eight meter high ceilings
underwent a lavish refurbishment the
Kurfurstendamm was badly damaged during
the Second World War a few of the
original buildings remain
Martin Drucker grew up on the boulevard
and he's seen a lot of changes the
coolest dumbest Canole Kurfurstendamm is
the same as any other place in bed
constantly in motion nothing stays as it
is it's like that here too this area of
the ku'Damm used to be home to cinemas
and cafes in the 80s and 90s this was a
kind of center of cinema culture really
old cinemas
two shops are moved in everywhere but
that's just the way these times change
Berlin gives in to lots of new trends
nothing stays as it is when evening
Falls the kurfürstendamm changes as well
from a hectic shopping street into a
real promenade that's when you can
really feel the atmosphere of the early
years the theaters bring life to the
streets adding yet another facet to the
kadam's unmistakable character